and you know you can't always be number
one you can't always be you know winning
every award but I think everything I
ever went through made me who I am and
motivated me more to be you know to
strive for what I wanted to do that I
want to be thinking twenty years from
now 30 years from now you know that's
always been my dream
hello bleep nation its Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves and my
sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
in your journey today we're going to
learn from singer-songwriter Mariah
Carey and my take on our top ten rules
for success rule number eight is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best also as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired by it as well and if you
leave it within the first couple hours
of this video going live you have a
chance to win one of two daily prizes
[Music]
in your voice is one of the more
extraordinary things in modern music
when in your life did you first realize
there's something special that comes out
of my throat the first time for me that
I actually felt it was when I was six
years old I was walking down the street
with this little girl we're singing at
the same time and then she stopped
singing and she started listening to me
and then I realized it and I stopped and
I was like what and she goes when you
sing it sounds like there was music with
you I never forgot that that was
something that made me feel special
because I didn't feel special as a kid I
felt different I felt weird I didn't
feel pretty didn't feel like I fit in I
didn't feel a lot of the things that
make kids develop their self-esteem that
moment stuck with me and made me feel
like no matter what that's in here and
that's something that nobody can take
every time I hear one of my songs on the
radio
I sit there and say okay now I should
have sang that line like this and done
that line like that or oh that's rancid
or whatever because I'm just never
satisfied with my work I always feel
like I could have done I could have done
it just a little bit differently but you
know I feel that for a first effort I'm
proud of it and I'm just looking forward
to completing the writing that I'm doing
for my second album right now and make
the best album that I can and just look
ahead and not look behind you set this
really substantial level of success for
yourself already do you feel like you
have to can always kind of stay at that
level or I don't because I mean I've
been very very fortunate to have what's
happened to me have happened to me and I
mean from now on all I really want to do
is continue to grow as an artist and to
just continue to putting out music and
hope people that have supported me will
stay with me and you know you can't
always be number one you can't always be
you know winning every award but I mean
just to be putting music out there and
to be having
some level of successes has always been
my goal what kind of student were you I
also read that your nickname was Mirage
because you were mirages in class here
there sometimes most the time you
weren't I mean I don't want to like
encourage anybody not to go to school or
anything you know I beat for me but I
liked school I always liked more social
in school than I was a student and and
you know I always knew I was gonna be a
singer that's like my thing I'm very
lucky that I am cuz right now who knows
what I'd be doing but I don't know I I
have trouble getting up in the morning
that's why I couldn't I couldn't take it
in the first period on time but I think
everything I ever went through made me
who I am and motivated me more to be you
know to strive for what I wanted to do
because sometimes if you're too
comfortable when you're growing up it's
just like yeah well I'll do this for a
while and I'll do that but I knew that I
had to go for it you're under a lot of
scrutiny you gone through a lot yeah a
lot in recent years so you must feel
particularly happy about the success of
this CD it's not just selling what was a
four hundred thousand in the first week
yeah
come back a lot of people are saying it
was over for you yeah you know a lot of
people were very ready to write me off
day lately and it's like you know I
never write off and I'm not trying to
whatever but there's certain people who
aren't friends with who people have
written off and they've come back to
have stellar years and I have never you
know written them off even if it was my
big moment and they were not having
necessarily such a huge moment they were
never written off in my book cause you
can't write off Talent so it's like when
people do that it's just not the right
it's not the right energy it's not the
right thing but yes it does feel good
and I got to thank my fans cuz they've
stuck with me and thank God it's over
you can't really fake it you kind of
have to love it that much to make
something that lasts this long people
consider fantasy of pivotal
groundbreaking kind of a moment for pop
music and for me I had the idea to use
the Tom Tom Club genius of love when I
was at an amusement park and I was
listening to the radio and it came on I
was like this is this be great
[Music]
your different versions of the song and
I think most people have the memory of
the one featuring ODB it was a classic
nobody expected it you know it took a
little bit of pushing and pressure from
to the record company because I don't
think they understood why I wanted to do
it and it's because I wanted to have a
hot remix but I was glad I got away with
doing it without the record company
listening to ODB's album because it has
certain topics on it that they may not
have approved of for me
a lot from the Whitney Houston
comparisons and continual surprise over
her vocal range
many were initially surprised that our
voice belonged to a white woman I don't
know everybody likes to put categories
on music and people and this is a black
sisters wife you know and I just really
don't think there's a need to categorize
everything I mean what I do is music and
music should be universal it shouldn't
be about this is too black this is too
white whatever you know I think
everybody can relate to music and that's
you know what it's all about you don't
really get a lot of credit for being a
great writer and having a teen number
one singles and I wrote 17 of them
that's the thing but people don't talk
about it because I think if you're not
if you're a female there's an issue and
if you're not strumming a guitar or
playing a freakin flute or a fiddle
suddenly like you're less of a writer
because that's not your process people
don't realize it like when I first
started out I made sure I hit a lot of
high notes
[Music]
if I just started out singing softly
only people wouldn't necessarily have
taken notice right I was just about the
voice do you consider yourself a writer
first or a singer first I do sort of
feel like I'm a writer first technically
I don't have to write the song in order
to sing it somebody could write a song
and present it to me I don't feel
fulfilled as an artist that way you said
your parents divorced when you were
three what was it like not having a
father around the house do you feel like
you missed out on anything I don't at
all I'm actually glad that I grew up
with just a single parent a single mom
because I think it made me more
independent you know I mean I'm not
gonna sit here and say oh I wish I had
the Brady Bunch family you know I used
to when I was little I used to want to
have the perfect family and I used to be
envious of people that had like the
perfect picture-perfect thing but
nothing's perfect so you know I'm glad
about everything that I ever went
through and I think that my mom is a
major reason why I'm here today I'm not
trying to prove anything I'm just really
trying to have a long career as a
singer-songwriter and I want to be
singing 20 years from now 30 years from
now you know that it's always been my
dream and it's incredible to be able to
have the success and I just want to
continue going
baby wave alone
Yeah right here don't worry ho I'm
signing hear me when I say it's all in
your mind
baby
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Alicia Maria
asked me to if there's someone you like
me to profile in their future top ten
please check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick sharda to Katy her
Elle Katie thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
working on the review for your channel
as well I really really really
appreciate the support and I'm so glad
that you enjoyed the read thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we can to need to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
everything that happens is like it just
a blessing and being so incredibly
fortunate to have be in the right place
at the right time and have all those
things and and everything but in
addition to that if you don't believe in
yourself you won't get to that stage of
even writing a song you know or you know
saying I'm gonna do this as opposed to
just saying well I'd like to be a singer
but you know probably that won't happen
because the only people want to do it
and you know why should I think I'm
special you know having someone telling
you that you are special and that you
can do it because the big thing how you
write a song starting with music you
starting with ideas for lyrics chorus
first versus first it's always different
there are times when a melody and a
lyric will come to me and they're
attached
it'll happen it'll be the inception of
an idea and then I'll continue it hero
was and we're going back but they asked
me to write a song for this movie it was
for Gloria Estefan supposedly to sing it
I don't know if Lauria knows that or not
[Music]
I left the room Oz with Walter a who I
used to collaborate with I took a walk
came back and I was like okay here's how
it goes and then a here comes along
and I started telling him like you know
play this and here's what it is
so sometimes it'll be like that
unplugged was really like the first
concert concert I've ever done and
people were waiting to hear like can she
do this so that's why there was that
type of pressure I was nervous because I
have so many high notes head and it
really requires me to isolate myself and
just the on vocal rest and not speak and
be like in a well humidified room and
sleep as much as possible because people
want to come hear my sound right I'm not
gonna go out there and be a mess